the greatest thing about cartoons is
watching a baby drown yeah I've always
really looked forward to that moment
it's pretty fun hey there yes thank you
for coming to my house say I Gary how
are you yeah we've obviously never met
and and I had to come over here because
I wanted to get your opinion on what's
it like to be in your head wait a minute
I mean is it like is there a connection
to reality that you know you're fibbing
or do you just live in total something
you do when you meet people a lot I had
you come over to my my place because I
want to show you some cartoons get your
opinions on them and then we're gonna
drop a psychological profile the first
one is called scrappy scrappy in the
little pest scrappy is a character we've
seen a lot and then this one right screw
these this is I have to say like this
but V scrappy no scrappy this isn't a
whole different scrappy
this ain't scrappy-doo no okay and this
is the first introduction of his little
brother oopy okay sorry so just to be
clear I'm about to meet scrappy and oopy
okay and and then the way these cartoons
were done is there's three animators and
they work together and they would each
take a third and do it and then not
really
apparently talk to each other I wonder
why they don't do a lot of projects like
that let's find out why that system also
works yeah
so it's let's roll it scrappy a newbie
mm-hmm there's scrappy okay so first of
all scrappy a child you find a bag of
cocaine mm-hmm giant head yeah Luna's
eyes mom wake up it's me scrappy dad's
gone I told you little pest told you the
name dog little brother who pee oh
that's it be the little brother yeah
boy oopy is the worst oh shut up
ooby No yeah I guess grab hold fishin
his head is his Brett is scholars and
fully formed yet scrappy see hippie but
it looks like nobody's going fishing
anyway he's an idiot yeah this is fair
this is what happens a little brothers
[Music]
poor dog
poopy just shut up and you can sneak
along right dog gets it
yeah there's not a water in teresting
the old penis farewell oh that's a dog
smack it across its mouth a few times
creepy okay all right
just stop saying that yeah echo wow wow
what an idiot OOP is don't hit me be
scrappy nice that is nice
poopy poopy what that's what happens
sure Oh God
[Music]
into the tree they go every fight yeah
and he took his clothes off well your
brother's dead even by the horror tree
yay
Oh does a brother never feel bad leaving
his baby brother naked inside of a tree
that was a different time
yeah now he puts on his clothes yep
that's what you do to babies really it's
it will die in the woods
nah baby so many babies have lived in
the woods weird that's really upset
of course the dog has a bugle oh right
yeah just get the eel army those are the
worms okay who wants in yeah they love
it that one's gonna die puts on some
makeup what's ready for the fish but
this worm really gets the sacrifice yeah
he's really into I think I shouldn't
drink that whoa thwack okay that's not
he's not gonna stay on the line by the
way they'll be fine
there's a fish nope no showing him his
bottom sort of he's gonna get fish
banged what is going on here oh the worm
was like olive - yeah it's smart Worman
by the way and you know what's our last
oopy check Opie is probably just fishing
okay there's a lot of fish here
he's the difference maker
[Music]
let's go on for a while yeah I've never
seen this in planet Earth
no no I'm bird isn't such a thing that
okay so don't want to kill your friend
what wait a minute they wouldn't be
alive well that's crazy that's the
craziest thing we've seen yet and I'll
tell you the craziest thing to do is eat
them thank God for can worms Jesus
anyway this goes on for a coupie do
something you stupid baby yeah more
likes to pee what so they just cannibal
I Oh he took his bones Oh God
I don't know much i but biology is not
like yeah that doesn't work
hey you pee it aint funny bro oh they
got him now they got him now that means
a lot are there Oh poopy poopy you're
gonna miss the day you were naked in
that tree ya later where's the baby in
the water now if it brings up a baby
skeleton less Fae
okay so who is in charge of the family
yay the greatest thing about cartoons is
watching a baby drown yeah I've always
really look forward to that moment it's
pretty fun you can do anything
no no plug his ears lock it out oh I
don't know I'm shy the dogs like what
are you come on wow we did it bro psycho
oh right that's right you'll be put an
electric chair and die so you might as
well save that baby haha his hearts in
the wrong place
if it wasn't for the electric chair he
would have been my boy that brother is
dead and he's dead oh this is like I
hope you enjoyed this guy ken is that
baby dead baby Oh God I mean it's Fareed
okay that's a lot of water
let's just be frank with what's
happening right now you're watching a
man shake a dead baby that's right and
drag it around drag it around I loves
his brother no he doesn't he doesn't
want the electric chair you idiot that's
what love is I want a drink of water
okay now killing em with mouthwash if
that hadn't happened there I was gonna
say kill me no I'm totally that that
ended appropriately you should kill the
baby at that point
okay so OOP he's dead yeah okay that's
all I guess I need a clarification on
yeah I mean threw him back in the water
so he's he's goner
all right so the moral of the story is
family's important family is important
don't don't kill your baby
[Music]
you